[Music]
thank you for joining us i'm john
langler even with
no concession from president trump
president-elect joe biden and his team
are getting to work
today he announced a new coronavirus
task force set to start on inauguration
day
skyler henry is at the white house
president-elect joe biden received a
briefing from his newly named
coronavirus advisory board
and then he addressed the news pfizer's
coveted vaccine
has been successful and is on pace for
approval this year
it's clear that this vaccine even if
approved will not be widely available
for many months yet to come
mr biden called for americans to unite
following the contentious election
in the name of public health doesn't
matter your party your point of view
we could save tens of thousands of lives
if everyone would just wear a mask
for the next few months cbs news has
learned the biden administration will
have a
series of executive orders ready to sign
on day one
the orders are expected to rescind a
travel ban on several muslim-majority
countries
reinstate the daca program and rejoin
the world health organization
and paris climate agreement however the
government agency that helps
start the formal transition process has
yet to sign the letter needed to provide
office space and funding
gsa administrator emily murphy a
president trump appointee
says the election has not yet been
decided president trump is currently not
planning to concede the race he
is mounting challenges in the courts and
the court of public opinion
cbs news has confirmed the trump
campaign plans to file
more lawsuits and they're encouraging
supporters to hold rallies
they've been losing every case that has
been brought post-election the trump
campaign has
and so it does appear it might be more
of a pr stunt than it is
an actual cohesive legal theory
president trump still has more than two
months as commander-in-chief
and he's not done changing up his senior
staff monday afternoon he announced on
twitter he has fired mark esper
the secretary of defense schuyler henry
cbs news
the white house after that tweet the
president named christopher miller the
director of the national
counterterrorism center
the acting defense secretary until the
biden administration takes over